whoa hi okay let my hand
please don't what does this button do oh
oh oh oh you [ __ ] are about to get a
face full of bullet because I am just an
old pro at this one you keep it up the
complaining because that means I'm gonna
win mine okay good job have you opened
your gun yet no see there's your problem
no but I'm gonna thank you for the got
it you guys boned
you guys are so bold oh my god this is
like a [ __ ] exercise in madness
you don't know madness until you know
what I've got inter-war yeah all right
I have gone open I have a bullet in hand
I'm about to put it in my bullets
backwards so does that matter is the
game gonna be forgiving no or I got a
bullet [ __ ] I have no bullets left
shut up it's gonna work it's gonna work
do I have a bullet my hand oh come on
okay I'm just touching my bullet there
you go nice wait I got it okay I just
gotta get it in the gun I don't get why
when you don't when you stop moving your
mouse your arm still moves yeah what the
[ __ ] that doesn't I can't I can't see if
the way you're holding your gun it's
like you've got to casually perched on
two fingers this doesn't suck you suck
please can some of you figured this out
and shoot me in the head
no can you grab the bullet for me which
one this one no not you gonna help him I
was gonna taunt him but it didn't work
cuz I come on no no it's cuz you're
stupid and it's your dumb
I can't they're too far who know I got a
finger on the gun I am rotating it into
position
oh god no no no no got it
no I got it no don't you slap my gun I
have not you guys are boned in the
extreme I'm not gonna have my gun in my
hand
I'm gonna keep the gun on the ground I
see the gun glitching that's great my
hand is here the bullet is touching it
but the bullet no going finger I am not
wearing pants by the way I just thought
you don't know don't touch my gun oh not
if you touch my gun he will murder you
yes yes hang on whoa what is your head
two guys drunk obviously deserves to be
shot I don't like you holding my head
but don't know what it's it's I can't
reach it
I care easy
I don't even have a gun man I know you
can help me win well I mean two of us
have to be shot before the end of this
so I guess at least we can do this we
can murder each other you just gotta
believe I want to break my own teeth
somebody just shoot me we're trying man
sometimes his fingers pinch a lot and
sometimes they don't pinch at all it's
cuz if what does hat what is why is a
chair on the table Wade flailing it like
an idiot doesn't help that's how I
opened the chamber the last two times
you gotta push the button there's a
button no idea we're doing the same
thing what it's like to have a Wade
brain playing
you guys are playing with your normal
human brains I'm full Wade over here
okay I'm back where I was oh just just
please please end me oh yes I have to
know I have to pull the trigger I have
to [ __ ] it back and then pull the
trigger
hang on I just need to get this gun in a
proper gun receiving position oh my god
someone hard enough to kill them no
don't touch my gun if I swear to god
wait I swear get the [ __ ] away right now
okay you're too late my gun is cocked
I'm ready to rock who's gonna get it
of a light of the shot look at you as I
do let me know if this is on okay here
comes the bang me finger okay don't you
move your head I'm not moving it's okay
I'm just gonna go for a body shot just a
maxima I can't pull the truth how do I
pull the trigger
Oh grab the bar I know I know you want
to end the suffering but I think I have
to shoot Wade just because I don't think
I physically can yes I'm going for it
this is gonna be the one all right now
it's just the two of us all right let's
call that a winner let's call that a
winner I was call Wade one because he's
the first one out of this I got it I got
it
Jack why did you drop yours you see us
right I knocked it over by acted like
you did man this games loud
now all the sudden can you turn mine off
okay hang on wait okay
I'm setting that down let's scared this
[ __ ] out of me a bit mark I'm sorry why
are you doing that why is why is my arm
going this way what is happening why no
guys I see only my crotch
what is that bang what's happening to me
you're so right there wait we can do
this we can do all right
yeah rip it off rip it off grab it grab
it rip rip the lid off bundle it off
especially which hair are you pushing
who's there push push ah okay I've got
two minutes all right perfect
oh wait I got it oh I ripped up yes yes
yes yes okay
she's off oh it's off its off okay no
wait no we're fine it's I think it's
fine okay you got it you got it no it's
fine read the instructions be - I got B
- okay all right moving c1 got it oh my
god you're a genius okay those are all
down remove fuse a fuse a it's it's
under the sheet under the sheet
show and move that sheet very carefully
I think we're good on time we should
probably book it oh yes oh [ __ ] [ __ ] set
the knob to one and enter the code one
five zero six four four oh oh oh that's
good
we push it there we go oh I don't know
where it went but I'm ok with it I got
it I got it we're good guys my arms are
broken I know guys well I don't what is
happening to me I can't move I can't
even look you it's it's all on you going
into the I see the bomb very closely oh
wait [ __ ] God I don't think we can do
it guys the only thing we've been able
to do is kill one of us
I got a bad feeling about this
just grab it and lift ah okay you're
right you're right you're right when
you're right you're right if you don't
get the grenade off in time if you pull
the pin and don't throw what you're
[ __ ] you don't know that at all you
guys are [ __ ]
you [ __ ] almost got that pin you guys
would have been [ __ ] okay
different plan of attack here gentlemen
don't you call me a gentleman you
delightful person I don't know on the
pin won't come out it's almost as if
they don't want you to just be able to
pull these out willy-nilly maybe you
have to grab it like you know finger
maybe you have to like you know what I'm
saying guys I totally get you man the
finger and the grab you get me let me
know if you guys are getting me I think
I'm getting comments subscribe if you're
getting me ring that bell if you're
getting me wait oh oh oh come on I did
it I did it
wait hang on I got throw it no I went by
me
oh oh that's how you're gonna be how
well two can play that game mr. really
candy you can I don't know if three can
play that game mister but I'm getting it
alright okay prove it prove it prove it
[ __ ] sorry I'm not as good as but
[ __ ] games as you are oh okay
alright what about wait what about wait
what about way yeah he's just a plain
being oh I got it I got it okay all
right who's gonna get [ __ ] who's gonna
get [ __ ] okay blow yourself up yes
it's not whoop
I'm gonna do I just don't want you to do
it I want you gonna do it guys grenades
are still exploding they're very potent
grenades couldn't do it wins that such
[ __ ] better than you but I can blow
up your [ __ ] Oh God
well it looks like it's just you and me
all right it's me the guy that can do
this and you the guy that can't I think
you have a better shot all right well a
little flourish on that all right here
we go
I did it all right I've got my pin out I
wasn't trying to blow myself up it just
happened was getting free stupid spray
[ __ ]
[Music]